I have magically deduced that you're answer is 3--tada. All right, now I'll show you how I did it.
I will not leave you in suspense for very long.
All right, so see if we can work out what's going on here.
This region here, this county is going to have to get some color
and it's ultimately not really going to matter which one it is.
So I'm just going to call it that. G is going to have a color that's different from H, so we'll call it that.
Now, we noticed that this region touches both of these two regions
so it has to have a different color than both of them.
This region touches both green and blue but not pink, so it has to be pink.
And d touches both pink and blue, so it has to be green.
And now we got these three regions and what do we know about these three regions.
Well, these two can't be green and they have to be different from each other,
so one of them is pink and one of them is blue and that means this one is going to have to be green,
but we don't know about these two.
So here's what I'm going to do, so I'm marking this sort of both pink and blue right there.
This going diagonal lines are--this one's pink, this one's blue,
and this going diagonal lines--this one's pink and this one's blue.
Regardless, it's going to turn out not to matter.
So now you don't have to assign number to green, pink and blue--0, 1 and 2,
but notice that we have G-A here and G-A, no matter what numbers you assigned,
they're going to be the same color.
So this has value of 0. It didn't matter what color C is, C*0 is going to end being 0.
So what we're left with is D+F+H, so D+F+H and notice that each of them are different colors,
so no matter what numbers you assigned to those three colors,
we're going to have exactly one of each.
The colors get assigned number 0, 1 and 2, so the sum is going to have to be 3.
So that's the trick